Let's go next to our caller from the three
one, three area code.
Who's calling today from three?
One three.
Hello.
Hey, that's you.
Okay.
Yep.
Hi, this is drill from Detroit.
Hey drill.
And I was just how you doing?
And I was just wondering, uh, what your take
would be on using your, your, your platforms,
one of the largest on the, on the, you know,
on the Internet on the left.
Uh, I was wondering what do you, would you,
what's your take would be on using it to like
get other, uh, smaller platforms known?
Uh, if you get what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So, um, you're using my platform to make other
platforms, no, you're saying like other, other
content creators or other, um,
yeah, yeah, the other car.
Yeah, that's what I meant.
Other context, like smaller ones, like a,
and I most people know destiny, but like people,
a lot of other streamers do a lot of good
work, uh, battling against, you know, horrible,
right wing ideas.
And I feel like some of them could use more
support.
Yeah, sure.
Listen, Jarell, I don't know if I, I don't
know if you're rubbing a banana on the phone
or something, but it sounds very, very odd.
I, I'm, I to the extent that I know of people
to promote that are doing good work, I'll
talk about them.
You know, the show mostly is about political
issues and topics.
So that's what the focus is.
But if there are specific people that I think
are worthy of a mention, I will certainly
talk about them.
Okay.
I'm gonna let you go.
Just cause that some, something is up with
that connection.
I don't know if there's maybe mice in your
phone or something like that.